how's it going brush mate
today we're checking out unreal 5
next-gen level graphics you know back in
my day anytime a new console came out it
was like
the newest graphics the most power now
there's no difference everything just
gets worse if graphics doesn't get
better then what's the point wow the car
looks a little bit more like car
i don't even know
i don't even know if i like the only one
wow the light is
okay now we're actually seeing some cool
stuff let's uh try this one hello i'm
siren and i'm a digital human
i was created by an international at
least she's not lying about it i don't
know i don't like when they lie about it
a team of artists and engineers who
wanted to challenge our ideas of what a
synthetic human could be
i've got state-of-the-art real-time
graphics and an unprecedented level of
detail in my eyes skin i feel like
you're building yourself up a little bit
here and i can tell you're fake
i'm actually being driven by a real
human actress and her dynamic motion
capture through unreal engine that's
cool so what are you waiting for come
meet me at the vikon booth and see for
yourself that's though it's actually
cool
2055. look how shitty our graphics were
back then
oh man
[Applause]
[Music]
see it's fake that's fake you create the
narrative no i know that one's fair the
japanese guy looks super fake
oh what it's like a template maker
that's sick
met a human high fidelity what okay
that's actually dope damn
see i've seen this one it came out a
year ago it looks so cool with the light
i feel like if there wasn't the girl
let's stop a moment i would actually
think this looks like a photo but
instead of using the game versions we
use the cinematic versions which would
typically only be used in film how do
you get that much 20 million triangles
each and thanks to virtual texturing
they all use 8k textures as well
there are over a billion triangles of
source geometry in each frame that nanox
losslessly to around 20 million drawn
triangles
stop
what does that many triangles look like
this isn't noise
these are the triangles each a different
color
that's so cool nanite achieves detail
down to the pixel which means triangles
are often the size of pixels that's so
cool on a geometric detail requires
shadows to be pixel accurate as well and
then i can do that too without gi
all of that beautiful lighting is gone
with lumen enabled we can move the light
damn
i was just gonna say what i thought i
was baking involved but now
i know it's not bacon and bone that's so
pretty damn
pretty cool
feels real
this is she she looks off everything
else looks cool
i guess it's always a challenge to do
people right
this swarm of bats was created with our
niagara effect system god damn
now that the environment whoa that's so
cool that kind of that kind of threw me
up for a minute i was like damn that
actually looks real we've needed to
greatly improve our animation systems to
adapt we've added the ability to trigger
seamless contextual animation events
like her hand on the door
okay
that's that's pretty dope
whoa
what
that has to be free render
it's time to see what's
next well this voice acting will still
be cringe apparently
some matrix uh the movie which in my
opinion the trailer looks so bad i can't
tell if they're trying to troll why does
it look so bad why is it filled with
russians this movie is so boring is it
alia oh it's not oh there you go i knew
it
what a shame because
these two are so awesome but man
sidetrack here but like the iconic green
tint
why would you
why would you get rid of that i don't
get it it just looks like uh
it just looks silly now it's interesting
i'm only pointing it out because now
when they did the unreal five promotion
collaboration they clearly understood it
and they're like yeah let's do the green
tint thing
[Music]
why can't they have done that anyway
this is such a brilliant collaboration
though because the original matrix
popularized again the concept of
assimilation what is real what defines
real welcome to the desert of the view
this is
an age-old question back to the greeks
back to plato and i'm sure people
thought about it even back then you know
what defines reality and now seeing
these uh photo realistic stuff
it's kind of it's such a good smart
collaboration but anyway let's check it
out reflecting back who and what we are
and the choices we make
fake worlds
they look so good though to confront us
with questions it's the hair and the
hair throws me the hair is too perfect
this over that
why we want to make x instead of a y
where do ideas of who we are and what we
want
[Applause]
i almost got it
for instance i'm not even sure why i'm
here
i remember waking up and thinking that
i'm supposed to come here
and the movement is low for me to ask
people
how do we know what is real
uh the hair the hair tiana
hi
i'm keanu reeves
over 20 years ago i first played the
character with thomas anderson in the
matrix trilogy those films pioneered
digital cinema with shots like that's so
cool he's in the scene
about where the digital age might take
cinema narrative
in an industry where actors have tried
to remain perpetually young
we wondered about digital faces that
could become immortal
hi
i'm carrie anne moss and i don't think
that's the real one i thought it was the
real one for a second
no it isn't
oh that's cool before faces and bodies
could be changed as easily as we change
clothes
we wondered what would identity mean in
their completely digital world
and what would reality mean
when a world we can build feels as real
as our own
[Music]
i love it for a second sometimes you're
like whoa oh oh that isn't real okay of
course but only for his tiny bay but
it's still enough to that it's fun
[Applause]
this is all computer mate right i think
it is yeah
what they wanted
they said they were fine with your
theoretical mumbo jumbo but they needed
some sexy action why
[Applause]
who said
the marketing people
i thought we were supposed to have total
creative control
welcome to the matrix so smart i love
this collaboration
[Applause]
wow
you still got it
like riding a bike
i sometimes miss this version of us
the hell are you doing back there why
does she look so fake so here here's the
gameplay from the demo that they added
and it's pretty cool man
if you don't really focus on anything
it's like whoa
[Applause]
that's insane
oh god don't even try to deliver it stop
it
when you see the background oh man
oh man it's so trippy
[Applause]
when everything's moving fast right you
can't really focus
[Music]
sorry boys
sick
sick it's the backgrounds and everything
the people are still off but still okay
look at anything but the people
okay the explosion looked fake as hell
but whatever
[Applause]
it's so trippy
they better not be lying unreal engine 5
if you're lying i'm going to be super
mad at you i want i don't
i want all games to look like this okay
you understand me they should've never
done the movie they should have done a
game so stupid god it pisses me off that
this movie exists i love the kiana i
really do but i don't get it man maybe
it's great i don't know i haven't
watched them no no i don't wanna if
you're a fan like me just lower your
expectations
for my expectations are already so low
the original matrix is my favorite movie
this is so such a fun film that mixes
philosophy action and love and romance
it's got it all baby i think what's
interesting about the concept of reality
is that you know the the idea that
we can recreate another reality i think
i made a video and i think the point
rather was that we shouldn't worry about
whether we live in assimilation or not
but we should worry about if we are
breaking down our reality
because we are already doing that in
terms of how we think as as a collective
in terms of how we perceive
things through advertisements uh through
fabricated experiences through
newspapers through media through each
other all these things affects how we
perceive reality
we just don't know we're not we're just
not conscious about it and that's why
we only look at other things and go well
that's not real what is reality and then
you can think about it beyond you know
obviously what time does it take for our
eyes to give us the image that is then
perceived in our brain and what the
shift between that time is a perception
of reality and they're also just a tool
built for us to perceive reality in the
way that we want it to but obviously any
other animal with different set of
optics is going to look at it in a
different way this is just a way for us
to perceive it and all this kind of
stuff it's but i think the point that i
mentioned earlier is the more important
one
if you wanted to really get into those
kind of discussions i mean take her out
of the picture and it looks so good
don't do that whoa
that actually works
yes it's beautiful it's gorgeous i love
it
this gets me hyped man anyway if you
enjoyed uh smash like subscribe see you
tomorrow with another video bye-bye